[Music]
Wow, look at this turnout. It's kind of
crazy how many people are excited to to
listen to Sarah and hear what notion AI
has been building. Uh so just going to
do some quick introductions before
handing it over to her. My name is
Carlos Esan. I'm a solutions engineer
here at Brain Trust. Uh so we're going
to Doug and I are going to share a bit
about Brain Trust after Sarah presents.
Um just wanted to say hi. You'll see me
talk a bit more today. Uh I've been at
Brain Trust for six weeks. Previously I
was at an infra company.
Yeah. The six weeks may be funny, but
also I'm the the veteran on the team. So
Doug here it's his third week. Third
week. So we're we're up here in front of
you and going to teach you about brain
choice in and eval. Um yeah, if you want
to go ahead. Yeah, sure. Uh solutions
engineer also alongside Carlos like you
mentioned. Been here a full three weeks
at this point. Actually, not even full.
It's like my I don't know 11th or ninth
day. Um but yeah, this is this is
incredibly exciting to to be here.
Obviously a lot of interest in in
Sarah's talk. Uh and hopefully we can
teach you a little bit about brain trust
in the process. So yeah, just want to
present Sarah. She's the lead of Notion
AI. They've been customers pretty much
since the the beginning of Brain Trust.
Definitely pioneered the platform and
yeah, super exciting to hear what she
has to say about their journey. Awesome.
Thanks. I've been using Brain Trust for
10 months, so I might be the most
experienced Brain Trust user on the
panel. Just kidding. Um, no, I mean I
think uh I want to save time for
questions too before we dig into the
workshop. I think at a higher level um
what I tell the team and what I tell
people who are also building is like all
of the rigor and excellence that comes
from building great AI products comes
from observability and good evals and
that's how you scale an engineering team
that's how you build good product and
ultimately we spend maybe 10% of our
time prompting and 90% of our time
looking at evals and iterating on our
evals and looking at our usage and brain
trust and that I believe is the right
balance of work in order to know that
you're not just shipping something that
worked well in a demo with your VP or
that you got working, you know, um on
the cow train to work and finally it did
what you wanted that one time, but
actually worked consistently and for the
for the users you were curious about.
So, I'll I'll speak a little high level,
save some time for questions, and then I
hope everyone um sees value in the
workshop as well because um it's really
a tool that is accessible to all
different levels. like you know I have
tech leads on our team that you know
themselves are true experts in brain
trust someone like me that might not be
necessarily executing experiments but
I'm in the platform every day and then a
whole host of data labelers and
specialists that work out of the
platform as well which we'll talk about
so um who here has used notion
okay love it here has used notion AI
okay some sales opportunities
um so what is notion AI That's me. Um
I've been at Notion for about 10 months
as I said. Um Notion, this idea, for
those of you that didn't raise your
hand, is a connected workspace. What are
we connecting? We're everything from um
workplace management, asynchronous work,
documents. Um but we also connect to
thirdparty tools like Slack and Jira and
Google Drive. Um we have a 100 million
users. Um over 100 million users now.
And uh something that's really important
to note about Notion AI is we offer a
free trial of all of our AI products,
almost all of them. Um and what does
that mean? It means that the scale that
we build for has to support that scale.
So if you looked at the balance of who
raised their hands, right? Maybe not
every user is an active notion AI user,
but the scale in which we support notion
AI, we want to offer it. So a new
feature for instance like concurrently
might have far more users than paid
enterprise plan users or people in our
business plan. And I like to think we're
known for our exceptional customer
experience. Um, we're certainly a design
driven company. Um, which is to say that
we care deeply about our product and
there's a lot of polish that's
associated with the brand. And polish is
not often associated with Geni
experiences. So, how do you add that
level of polish and care into what
you're building um while still building
at the speed and rate of acceleration
that exists in the industry, right? Um,
for instance, we're very proud that we
partner with a lot of foundation model
providers. We also fine-tune our own
models. Anytime a new model is released
within um, usually less than a day,
we're able to give that to all of our
users in production. Um, in order to
move at that pacing um, but still have a
polished product, you need to have
evaluation
with a with a product like Brain Trust.
So, here's um, our latest launch. This
was uh two weeks ago a suite of projects
that we just launched with AI.
Okay, no audio but I'll give you a
little voice over. Um so AI meeting
notes is kind of our first
[Music]
so we now have text to speech or speech
to text excuse me along with
transcription AI generated summaries and
fairly soon you'll be able to see those
also interact with your task database
your whole workspace workspace awareness
when talking about action items. Um, we
have an enterprise search product that
when you're searching can search across
everything. I use this constantly,
particularly in standups when they're
talking about Slack threads that are
like 50 messages deep that I stopped
following at 10 p.m., right? I can use
Notion AI. And for much deeper searches,
we have a deep research tool. um that
deep research executes parallel
searches, serves a lot of our fine-tune
agentic capabilities
um and is kind of our first transition
out of workflows into agents where
rather than having like a set list of um
tasks or flows that your AI um program
is running through, uh now we're giving
it the reasoning capability to decide on
different tools and and spend longer on
the work that it's doing. So that's
notion AI for work. Um that's the latest
suite that we built. Um, and I'll talk a
little bit about what we've learned um,
as we've built um, this latest suite and
as well older generation notion AI
products.
See,
no, we already watched that.
Okay, so believe it or not, Notion AI
actually came out before Chat GPT. um
that's kind of its own story that none
of you are here to hear about, but we
had early access to the generative
models and always believed that content
generation was core to how notion
worked. So our first product launched
right around the same time. It was
called the AI writer. It allowed you to
generate just in line, you know, write a
sentence about XYZ, right? From there,
we started building autofill. Autofill
is our AI kind of agent that lives in
every database property. Notion allows
you to have databases. Now all of a
sudden the AI is not just acting on the
page but is acting across the database
and is triggered frequently and is doing
things like translating things so that
every column is in a different language.
This is where we started seeing a lot of
usage that was more unpredicted from our
users. And it's around the same time
that we also started building um a core
AI team. Then we built kind of a natural
rag solution. This was kind of the um
uh I should say like the first time that
we had like a full data platform AI full
collaboration and this is where we
started offering for instance Q&A to
like free users. So we have to have
embeddings for everyone. We have to
think about multilingual workspaces
things like that.
And then now we get to the era where we
started working with brain trust. So you
saw you could search across all apps. We
launched the idea to have attachments.
Um, a lot of people use notion as file
storage or they'll upload things to
notion. We can search over those
attachments. And finally, the things
that we just talked about. So, one thing
I want to note is that we didn't start
with what I just showed you. And I think
that would have been quite naive.
Obviously, with the technology we have
today, that would have been quite easy,
but we also knew that we didn't have the
technology to build those things yet.
And we worked really with where the
models were most capable.
Um, what makes it hard to evaluate? So
number one um these are exceptionally
large data sets. Notion's really lucky
because we use notion constantly when we
work on notion and so we can generate a
lot of training data or evaluation data
just from our own dog fooding. Um I
think that's actually one of the unique
advantages that allows us to be one of
the more fast-paced enterprise AI
solutions. Um similarly our human
evaluators were just exceptionally
overwhelmed like how do they look at I
think we were like they were working in
Google sheets. I think we hurried them
even before we onboarded notion. We have
data specialists and they were looking
at this like dump in Google Sheets and
trying to figure out how to parse the
prompt with like a Google sheet formula,
right? And figure out what did the user
actually say? How do I play with a few
shots? It's very um involved and I think
anyone that utilizes human labelers well
um and it's also been proven in research
is that particularly when it comes to
fine-tuning but also iteration, quality
is much more important than quantity um
in terms of the insights and things that
you extract. Um, and so we definitely
needed a scalable efficient solution to
support how we were looking at our data
and also keeping track of user feedback.
All of the thumbs downs that we were
getting in the development usage.
So this is kind of what our iteration
cycle looks like. So let's say that we
want to decide on an improvement. So for
instance, let's say that we wanted to
launch a Jira connector in our universal
search product, right? What does it mean
to query on Jira? How do I have my AI
even figure out what's a task? it's a
sprint. Um how to query from the Jira
workspace. Um we then curate targeted
data sets from that workspace. Um you'll
hear me keep mentioning these data
specialists. Uh for much smaller
enterprises that might be your PM that
might I would highly encourage it to
also be your engineer. It should be the
people that are closest to the data.
We're at a scale now where we have a
specialty that's kind of like an LLM
trainer that's a mix of a PM and a data
analyst and a data annotator. Those are
our data specialists. But they are
creating just from logs and using a
product and prototype handcrafted data
sets. Um those can be 10 things right
but I would actually let's pause make it
10 things first and make sure that it's
formatted the way that you want. We have
definitely done the bad thing of
creating lots and lots and lots of dummy
data and it's not structured the way we
want and that's a real pain. So first is
like making sure everything is
structured and your data flywheel is set
up successfully to get insights that you
might want. Then we tie them to scoring
functions. Um, scoring functions should
come after you've looked at the data for
a long time. There are a lot of out- of-
the- box scoring functions. We don't use
them frequently. Um, we tend to use
things that are specific to the product.
Um, I'll talk a bit about the LLM as a
judge process that we use. That's
probably what we rely on the most. But
there are also a lot of things that are
heristic based. So for instance, if I
have um if I want to make sure that my
reasoning model triggers querying from
Jura appropriately, everything in that
data set that tool call should have in
its query must be Jira, right? And so we
can also make deterministic functions.
Um similarly, we have a data set of
places where there are multiple
languages happening and we know what the
output language should be. So for
instance, Toyota is a large C customer
of ours. Toyota might be working in
Japanese and English. Someone might be
asking questions in Japanese, but the
output might be like, "Write me a
paragraph about XYZ they're asking in
Japanese." And like the lucky job of the
product team is to figure out what
language they actually want the response
to be, right? It's a hard problem to
have. We'll have a data set of those as
a curated brain trust data set so we can
before we ship anything run that EVAL
and make sure that we don't break the
multilingual language context switching
experience. Right? So for certain
experiences, we actually run the eval
kind of like an ad hoc CI um experience.
I think there are some companies that
actually integrate in CI. We don't do
that currently, but you could. Um that's
more just to do with how long it takes
to run the evals and how CI is built at
notion. Everyone submitting code would
run evals and that'd be a lot. Um we we
inspect the results and then we keep
working. Um the other thing I'll say is
it's not just engineers that are on
Brainest. Because of that, we often will
have like our PMs in brain trust working
very closely. So for instance, for that
research mode product, we found that
people were trying to draft reports much
more than they were just trying to do
research. And we found that by looking
through all of that thumbs down data
that was propagated into brain trust um
from internal dev usage. That's
something that we could escalate to our
um PM. But we also want the product
thinkers and the designers to be
thinking about that as like a first
class citizen. You can think of this as
your version of UXR, right? Um, is to
actually see what the model's doing well
and how people end up wanting the model
to do different things for them.
Um, and then in terms of that feedback
by development, I want to talk a little
bit about the LLM as a judge system.
There's kind of two components that I've
seen uh pretty prominently in industry.
One is LLM as a judge in which you have
one prompt which judges everything in
your data set. So for instance, uh, is
this information concise? um is this
information faithful? Those are very
common types of LLM as a judge prompts.
There's another version of it um which
is a little bit more laborious um from a
creation standpoint, but I find to be
far more insightful, which is for every
single element in your data set or trace
or whatever it is that you're um
evaluating. Um you have a particular
prompt. So for instance, I might write a
prompt that says this answer should be
in Japanese. The bullets should be
formatted this way and it should answer
XYZ and point to page A. Right? This is
because obviously Levvenstein distance
isn't going to do a very good job of
capturing the expected value to what we
want, but we actually know exactly what
we want the output to look like and we
don't want to have too conservative of a
prompt that will always break. For
instance, just having a golden piece of
data saying this is what the output
should look like. We actually just say
like what are the rules for what we
want. This works really well with search
evals actually um because our index is
always changing. um when we want to
re-evaluate how search retrieval goes,
we say the first result should be the
most recent element in the list about
the Q1 offsite, right? And maybe since
we redid that, maybe since we created
that element in our data set, there's a
new document about the Q1 offsite that
wasn't what was in our golden set. This
allows your golden set to be much more
up-to-date and current. Um yeah, and so
I highly suggest that. Um and that's
actually what our um data specialists
run. And what's really nice about it, as
I mentioned earlier, our ability to
switch to new models. Um, this can
output a score that's far more reliable.
Um, and from that score, we can quickly
understand if a new model has any
serious regressions. Um, and this allows
us to, um, given like our modular
infrastructure of different prompts for
different tasks and different models for
different prompts, we can really quickly
say, okay, Nano came out. Um, nano is a
fairly effective model that's very fast,
maybe lower reasoning, and very cheap.
What are kind of the high frequency use
cases where we don't need advanced
reasoning, but we do want it to be able
to run quickly. Let's gather those and
with one button run all of the evolves
on them, see which prompts it does or
doesn't do well on, and then quickly
just change to those prompts, you know,
and that cycle can become very fast. Um,
and that allows us to stay at the top of
the frontier in a way that I think has
really been advantageous for us as a
customer and more importantly um, for
our users.
Um, and the outcomes have been crazy.
Um, I don't think that we could exist
without brain trust or a similar type of
software today. It is critical to our
iteration flow and it actually is our
IP. So everything that we build, the IP
comes from how we evaluate it and how we
build it and that comes from where we
build on top of brain trust. Obviously,
we have prompts that are like a series
of strings and obviously we have code
that navigates through them, but how we
decide if those work well is just as
critical and how we decide on model
selection and all of that lives inside
of brain trust. Um, similarly, our AI
product quality has skyrocketed because
now we have observability. 60% of notion
enterprise users aren't speaking
English. I will tell you a 100% of
notion AI engineers are speaking
English. So, how do we build something
that works for majority non-English
speakers? We have to use rigorous
evaluation metrics that understand that
multilingual experience.
I think that was the last slide I
prepared. I want to save some time to
answer any questions that you guys might
have. Um yeah, I think there's a mic if
you want to or you can just scream it
and I'll repeat it. That might be
faster. Uh you had a question. So for
the LM judge, so what you were saying is
actually you guys have multiple judges
and each responsible for
anything to check.
Yeah, the question was um for LLMs as a
judge, do we we have she wanted to
clarify that we have multiple judges
each responsible for a smaller thing?
The answer is yes. Uh let's think about
it in terms of um scope of what they're
evaluating and magnitude of number of
samples that they're evaluating. Um,
usually we have a variety. Sometimes we
have like a onetoone mapping where for a
single thumbs down output, we just have
a prompt that is shared with no one else
and that's what we engineer. We have
some layers on top of brain trust that
make that easier for our data
specialists to write that work with the
brain trust um SDK. But we have that and
then we also have LLMs as a judge that
will operate on top of everything um
that's in that data set. You'll learn
more in the workshop the distinctions
with like data sets themselves and logs
but data sets are hand curated and it
can be just one aspect of your trace. So
in an AI interaction you can have like
five five LLM calls that happen between
the user and like the notion AI
response. We can extract just one of
those and put it in a data set. Yeah.
Yeah. Have you tried doing any like
automated prompt optimization or is it
generally like you you'll have to go
manually through a person go look at the
results and then update them. The
question was about automated prompt
optimization. The answer is yes. We have
played with it. I'm not sure that a
majority of our problems are as solved
by that as they could be in other
workplace contexts. I've been to like
dinners and events where I've heard
massive success from it. Maybe we
haven't cracked it yet. Um, a lot of
people have, but we've played with it.
Yeah. One quick question. Yeah. What's
your process of aligning the thumbs up,
thumbs down with the scoring function?
Yeah, the question was about aligning
thumbs up, thumbs down with scoring
functions. Um, they don't I mean, so a
majority of things in our data set were
things that are either thumbs up or
thumbs down. Sometimes it's just legally
how it works because we have a process
with some alpha users where that's the
only way they give us permission to look
at their data for evaluation purposes.
Uh we don't really rely on thumbs up for
anything except for maybe internal
notinos thumbs uping things as like good
golden data for fine-tuning, but we
don't really rely there's like no
consistency in what makes someone thumbs
up something. So we don't look at that
that closely. And for thumbs down data,
um it's more just that this is a
functionality that we know we didn't do
our best work on. Um but that thumbs
down could have been given in September
of 2023. Um and so we don't perform how
we did in September 2023. So it doesn't
necessarily align with the LLM as a
judge because that's judging a
particular experiment, not um what the
production user experience was at that
time. And that's what makes this really
powerful because we don't just need to
look at what our output was in September
2023, right? Our data can be far more
robust and last much longer because
really what we're getting from the
thumbs down is the natural language
request from the user. Everything else
we can remodify. We know the state of
their workspace and what their request
was. everything else you know we as our
server code changes changes the output
of the LLM and the engine.
Any other questions? Yeah. Yeah. Uh for
the LLM as a judge is the scoring more
like binary or is a scale? Yeah. The
question was if LLM is a judge scoring
as binary or a scale? I'll tell you like
the honest answer in practice. I believe
that we do it as a scale and I don't
think that scale is very well uh
calibrated and I believe that we just
grap everything that's less than a
certain score and look at them as all
equal. Um that's just like how we do it.
I'm sure that there are technical ways
that I've read about people that run it
multiple times and calibrate their LLMs
as a judge. For us, we still have humans
look through those outputs. We actually
will take the failures and pass them
into another LLM and ask them to
summarize what the failures are so that
we can write a quick report for the
engineer working on it to see because we
have thousands of samples. So then we
actually look at those deltas and pass
it to another LLM to tell us what the
biggest themes in difference were. Um
yeah, that's how we do it. I actually
think there's been a lot of academic
research on that calibration, but it has
not been necessary for us from an
investment perspective. Um so we haven't
worked on that much. Followup question
for that. Uh so when you change models
or when you change prompts there uh
there are two types of evaluation. One
is you can subjectively say hey is this
uh safe is this trustworthy or more like
finally yes or no. Uh and other thing is
when you change from the results you can
compare it pair wise but is this result
better or you combination? Yeah the
question was about pairwise combinations
um versus just saying yes or no. Um it
depends on the experiment that we're
doing. Um, oftentimes if we're
experimenting between two methodologies,
yes, or if the control is particularly
important, like this is what's in prod
and I don't want to break prod um, then
we will use that kind of AB um, setup.
If it's the development cycle that I
talked about earlier where we're still
in dev or we're still just with alpha
customers and we don't know what the
golden experiences and we're far more
comfortable breaking things, we're much
more we're much less likely to use that
type of setup. But Brain Trust actually
has a great UI for letting you do both.
Yeah. Yeah. Curious if you have a
process around figuring out what
criteria to judge a feature. Um like is
there any best practices or is it The
question was about criteria to judge as
a feature. Um I mean there I'm sure
there are best practices. I think for us
the reminder
so like you know there's thousands of
these and then they live in this ether
and it's maintained by the people that
wrote them and then they take on a lot
of power right and very few people
actually investigate the losses and
that's really risky for building a
robust enterprise application um so
things that we've learned lessons that
we've learned because that and I see
some people nodding you can imagine how
that's a little bad sometimes for
instance we used to use them just to
catch specific regressions. Like we have
a special markdown format that works
with notion. We just use them for
formatting at first. Um and we'd be like
uh has to you know be consistent with
our markdown and use bullet points and
has to talk about this topic. All of a
sudden we weren't catching that it would
like switch languages because that's
true in that prompt, right? And so then
when you start relying on it to catch
everything or to be like a yes for
something then you have a problem where
you're overrelyant on it and you're not
catching regressions. So there's kind of
two approaches that I would suggest that
make that successful. One actually goes
back to your very intuitive question
which is um having it for particular
task. So we have a particular task of
markdown formatting. We have a
particular task of language following.
um we don't assume that they can do
everything or you have a very small set
and commit yourself to looking at the
losses. The problem is you don't commit
to the losses and you know that they're
lossy. Um I think that's like a trap
that we certainly um fell into when we
were first developing this concept about
nine months ago um before they were
called LLMs as a judge. Um we just were
LLM graders, right? Um I would say
that's like kind of the two biggest
pitfalls. Yeah. Um do we have time for
more or it's up to you? Yeah, we can do
a couple more. Okay. Um, yes. How do you
isolate rag versus generation?
How do we isolate rag versus first
generation is a very good question. Um,
are you asking about well do you mean
like in terms of how we evaluate it? How
we evaluate changes? Yeah. How do you
Yeah. So um this has more to do with
like an what you're experimenting
against. So for instance there are times
where um the index itself changes when
you're doing an evaluation and things
like recent docs particularly for
retrieval freshness of the index or the
index at time of evaluation are
exceptionally important and can
definitely change the downstream results
which can be unobservable and confusing
to the raider or to anyone looking at
the evaluation. So when is our next
offsite you know maybe I did that before
our Q3 offsite and it's it's Q1 right
now right? So like the answer would
change. One approach is to create a
technology that freezes that index.
That's actually really expensive because
you don't know what elements of that
index you want to freeze. You don't know
what the query is. It's a lot of
storage. What we have found is that we
freeze the retrieval and take the
retrieve results and operate on like did
this retrieval actually retrieve the
right thing. We operate on that as its
own evaluation that has its own
evaluation framework that has much more
to do with like our vector databases and
elastic search setups. And then we have
a retrieval that says like presume that
this is what was retrieved. Execute
everything else but like what was
actually returned is frozen. And then
the point in which the index the point
in which like the actual answer wasn't
in that index and the eval can't be
done. We just get rid of that sample. So
we either assume that retrieval worked
or just do the re- retrieval. We don't
really merge them very much for that
exact reason. Yeah. Just follow up.
Yeah. So do
Do you isolate the retrieval at the time
of creating the data set? Yeah, do we
isolate retrieval at the time of
creating? Um, it kind of depends on what
we're building and what we have like
access to. The answer is a majority of
the time we try really hard not to find
what the index looked like at that
period of time. That's very technically
difficult. Brings up privacy questions.
Um, for instance, the permissions of
that object could have changed. Um, we
try not to do that. Yeah. But we also
get enough feedback where it doesn't
become as frequent of a problem again
because we're we're lucky in that we use
notion so much that we get a lot of
natural particularly for retrieval
natural use cases. Let's do maybe one
more two more. One more. Let's do
someone from the back. Yes.
How many prompts do we have? Um I don't
think this is private. Um let me think
about if it would be we have over a
hundred like hundreds. Um
how do we manage dependencies? Um I mean
some of them well we have our emails for
them and that helps a lot. A lot of them
are different variations of things. Um
for instance like there's some model
specific variations on our prompts. Um
we have a large team. It hasn't really
come up. I think the only time that
managing a large number of prompts has
been a problem is when a particular uh
model provider has an outage and we need
to switch traffic over to other model
providers. It's not like all 40 mini
traffic can just go to sonnet 37 um for
a variety of reasons. Obviously that
works for a lot of it. It's like okay
I'm willing to pay more for a small
amount of time until openi comes back
up. But for some of them like our
database autofill you know it's 12 times
more expensive. we'd have like millions
and millions of dollars of of debt for
that decision in that in that period of
time. Um, and we can't make that. And so
I think it comes more to like ownership
over prompts and making sure that a
fallback mechanism is up to date. Um, so
that whoever's on call, they can just
say like, you know, uh, 40 is down and
we can automatically for the owner of
that product or that prompt, they've
already determined what to switch to
instead in like a code-driven or config
based mechanism. Um, I would say that's
been the most laborious aspect is like
getting everyone together and creating
that system. I wish we did that from day
one. We did it more recently. Um, and
that was kind of like a tribal of
elders. Everyone that's ever written a
prompt, please come and fill out this
config. Um, but otherwise it hasn't been
a problem yet.
Yeah. Great. Thank you. Thank you
everyone.
Yeah, notion AI is my lifeline. It's
great to search on there. I gives me all
the answers I need.
She did not endorse this.
Okay, great. So, we are the Brain Trust
speakers uh the the two left here on the
on the podium and uh we'll be going over
some lectures, then jumping into the
platform. you'll do an activity, then
we'll come back,
cover a new topic, and uh so on. So,
we're going to start with just covering
why Eval, what is an eval, what is an
eval, excuse me. Then we'll talk about
running the same thing via the the code
via the SDK in this case in Typescript.
Then we'll move into production. So, day
two, how are you logging? How are you uh
looking at the data points that you're
collecting in your production
application? And then uh finally
covering human in the loop. So how do
you incorp incorporate user feedback or
uh actual human annotators to improve
the quality of your prompts improve
improve the quality of your data set?
And if we have time at the end we'll do
some remote evals stuff which extends
what the UI is capable of in the
playground specifically.
I think we have a poll in the Slack
that's currently pinned. If you're part
of the Slack channel, feel free to add
your response there.
So, jumping into evals and getting
started.
These are some of the curated uh tweets
that we've seen notable people uh talk
about online. So, just something to to
think about why it may be so so useful
for them.
Well, it helps you answer questions. So
again, you know, is my change regressing
uh the performance in production? Am I
using the best model for my use case,
the cheapest model for my use case? Does
it uh have brand consistency in its
responses? Am I learning from the data
that I'm capturing from the logs? Uh and
am I able to debug and troubleshoot some
of the responses that are
underperforming?
This is a trend across the whole
industry. Everybody's dealing with
hallucinations and uh performance
degradation. And so we're here to to try
to set up a system using statistical
analysis to catch these mistakes uh
proactively and also with online evals
reactively on that online traffic.
This can help your business by allowing
you to move faster, helping you reduce
costs and uh scale teams. It's really
helpful to have nontechnical people
collaborate with technical people to
build the best AI apps possible by uh
using the playground for nontechnical
people and then having that SDK
compatibility and everything centrally
managed in one place.
Moving into the core concepts of brain
trust. So you can think of it in these
three slivers. Starting off with prompt
engineering, right? You want to keep
track of the versions of the prompts
that you're uh iterating on. uh you want
to do this rapidly. So having a
playground or a place where you can
quickly go through these changes and
identify improvements or regressions is
is really crucial. Uh then you want to
have evals that are automated ideally,
right? And this can be kicked off via
the SDK. Uh you'll have a score that is
from 0ero to one as a percentage that
will give you a signal of is this going
up, is this going down, what needs
attention, what doesn't. And then
finally, observability. What's happening
in production? Are users uh thumbs uping
or thumbs down? Are they providing uh
ideal output that I can then use in my
data set to keep improving the evals or
keep improving my AI feature?
So, jumping into you know what what even
is an eval? Well, the definition that we
come up with is that it's a structured
test that checks how well your AI system
is performing. It helps you measure
quality, reliability, and correctness
across scenarios. Again, the the
criteria is really up to you. As we
heard Sarah say, the LLM is a judge can
be across whatever dimension you want to
to test.
There are three components that go into
an eval. So, you have your task, which
is the thing that you want to test. This
is the code or prompt that you're
evaluating. It can be a simple, you
know, one-time call to an LLM or a full
agentic workflow. The complexity is
really up to you. Uh we'll see some
simpler versions in the UI and then in
the SDK, it's really, you know, the
complexity is up to you. You can you can
go crazy there. Uh the next piece is the
data set. So this is the set of real
world examples, the test cases that
you're going to be throwing at the
prompt and seeing how it's performing
based on the score output. Right? So the
score is the logic behind the eval. This
is outputting from 0 to 100 a score. You
can use LLM as a judge or full heristic
functions. So it's it's great to use a
combination of the two and try to meet
in the middle.
There are two mental models to think
through. Offline evals, which are evalu
iterating on the prompt, figuring out
what works best or what model to go
with. uh you're writing these structured
tests and running them through these
predefined data sets, right? You're not
using live traffic in this scenario. Uh
but on the online eval side, you are. So
this is real-time tracing. You're
monitoring that live production
application and you're also getting
scores from those real outputs. And that
will allow you to diagnose problems,
monitor performance, and and capture
that user feedback so you can keep
improving and and close that that
feedback loop.
So we'll show how you can use both of
these types of of eval.
This matrix here is really helpful to
understand what should I even be
improving you know and you have to look
at two things right the score that's
being output by your evals and using
your own eyes looking at the output of
the LLM. Do I think this is a good or
bad output? If both match, you look at
the prompt, it's good, high score,
great. That's that's where you want to
be. But if not, you have to decide,
okay, do I want to improve my evals, the
actual scores, or do I want to improve
my AI app? And this is not very trivial.
You there there does require uh some
thinking of of what what requires um my
focus improving the eval improving the
the actual app.
So now zooming into each of these
components. So the task, this is the
thing that you want to test. Uh so
starting off with a prompt, right? This
is a screenshot from the UI. It's the
input that you're going to give to the
LLM, right? Uh you can set up a system
prompt in Brain Trust and then pass uh
user prompts as mustache templating and
that's something that we'll see in the
activity shortly. Uh so you know this is
uh great for getting started. You may
have some multi-turn use cases where
you're having a whole conversation and
you want to evaluate that uh with a tool
like brain trust. So that's where extra
messages comes in and you can provide
the the system prompt followed by the
user message, the assistant response,
the user response, the assistant
response, maybe a tool call thrown in
there, right? All of that prepackaged
and given at once to your eval system.
uh that will then output a score.
Tools are also used uh with brain trust
and they should be for you know rag
applications or for agentic
applications. Uh so this can live in
brain trust. You can push your tools to
the brain trust library and they'll
become accessible to anybody playing in
the playground or running experiments.
Um
and the last piece here in the task are
agents in the UI. So now you can have
prompts chained together where the
output of the first prompt becomes the
input of the next.
This is going to keep uh increasing in
in scope within brain trust. You we'll
have branching and more capabilities.
This is currently a beta feature. Uh but
really exciting to be able to do
endtoend evals on prompts being chained
uh as many as you'd like.
So now moving into data sets. So there
are three fields right three columns in
a data set one of which is required the
input field. Uh so this is what's like
going to be passed into the prompt. This
is the the user uh input into your AI
feature application. Right? Uh the other
two columns are optional. You can have
your expected column which would be that
anticipated output or that ideal
response. Uh this is difficult to create
initially. Uh, and we see a lot of
customers leave this blank at first and
then start to fill it in with uh, human
annotation or user feedback. Um,
if you're doing a rag bot, it's common
to have like assertions. So, what do you
want to be included in the output?
Providing that in the expected column
will help uh, make sure that that it's
using that as the ground truth. And then
metadata is for any additional
information that you want to track at
that specific uh, data set row. So with
the specific user prompt.
So some tips here. We recommend for you
to just get started. The you don't need
to create 200 rows in a data set to run
your first eval. You know 5 10 rows is
great. Just start small and get some
feedback. And you know the next thing is
don't stop iterating. keep adding rows
or tweaking rows using logs as that that
source of truth, right? How are your
users interacting with the feature that
you're developing?
Of course, at first you may not be
capturing logs, but there's still that
that process whether it's via synthetic
data or with internal testing that you
can uh help yourself improve the data
set. Human reviews is another way of
establishing ground truth. Very much
needed in certain industries. If you're
dealing in the medical space, you need
doctors to look at the output or you
need lawyers or people with highly
specialized skills.
Cool. So now moving into the score
types. Uh so this is the last piece. So
we covered task, we covered data sets,
and now scores. Uh so there's uh two
types, right? We covered the LM as a
judge a little bit. So this is
subjective non-deterministic more of a
qualitative assessment uh that will be
done on the output and then on the other
side there's a full codebase heruristic
score this is very exact deterministic
objective so you want to try to use a
combination of the two and like I said
meet in the middle right uh
there are some organizations that will
choose to go one way or the other but we
found that most will typically
incorporate both as much as they And uh
I know Sarah mentioned that LM as a
judge has been crucial for her.
So some tips here. So we recommend for
you to use a higher model in the LM as a
judge to evaluate the smaller ones. Just
something that we've noticed could be
useful. Uh then you want to make sure
that the the judge is scoped to a
specific criteria. uh we want it to to
be focused and not be a broad uh
decision that it has to make across five
or six different criteria.
You want to make sure that you're
evaling the score. This is probably the
most crucial piece, but you want to put
the score prompt, the LMS judge prompt
through the same rigor that your other
prompts are receiving, right? So, you
want to make sure that you're testing it
on uh human annotated feedback. So what
would a human think looking at the same
outputs? Is it matching the LLM as a
judge? If not, probably needs some
improvement.
This is a little uh tidbit about the
brain trust UI. So we have two views,
playgrounds and experiments. They look
very similar. Uh this wasn't always the
case historically, but they've now grown
to be very similar because of customer
requests. Uh the playground, a way to
think of it is quick iteration. It's
more ephemeral, right? So what you do in
the playground won't necessarily stick
around and be part of the historical
view. But you can always save a snapshot
of it to the experiments view and and
sort of bring it over and that will then
kick off the more traditional
experiment. Uh which is the same thing
that happens when you run an experiment
via the the SDK, right? So you run an
eval via the SDK or from your CI
pipeline that will end up in the
experiments view. And the benefit of
that is that you have everything in one
place that you can review and compare
across weeks and months. Uh so you can
compare your performance with the new
model that dropped today with a prompt
from 3 weeks ago in the experiments view
and see the scores change over time.
Cool. So th that was probably a lot, but
now you understand the components and
ingredients behind
running an eval. So, now we're going to
jump into the activity. There should be
a document pinned in the Slack channel.
If not, we can also pull up the uh QR
code quickly, but if you can pull that
up and try to follow along, I know the
Wi-Fi has been a little spotty.
If you can't follow along, no, no
worries at all. Uh Doug here will be
leading through uh those steps.
All right, let's have a little fun here.
um actually getting our hands dirty with
the the Brain Trust platform. As Carlos
mentioned, we have
uh sorry, wrong button. Uh the the uh
the document guide out here that'll I'll
walk you through the setup of uh the
workshop. Um I'll I'll again I'll walk
through it. It'll give you sort of
enumerate uh the different requirements
that you'll have to have at least for
how it's set up today. Just as like a uh
call out here, we're using OpenAI here
under the hood. That certainly doesn't
mean that Brain Trust only works with
OpenAI. You can use any sort of AI
provider, uh, custom AI provider. Uh,
you can sort of bring your own here as
well. But just wanted to call out, we're
going to use OpenAI here to to do this.
Another thing to call out, uh, somebody
ran into this in our last workshop is
the particular version of Node that
you're using. Uh, just don't be on
version 23. Uh, 22 20 are are generally
pretty good ones to to use. And then,
uh, let's get going. Uh so you can you
can start here at the top by installing
node git and typescript. I've already
done this here on my machine but uh you
can get a sense for uh for what this
looks like. Um obviously we we need a
brain trust uh organization and a
project here to actually go and play
with that playground uh create some of
eval um run some experiments. So if you
go to ww.brain.dev
this is where you can create your your
organization and your project.
Uh we're calling our project unreleased
AI today. You could certainly call it
something different. You would just see
multiple projects be created inside of
your account. And I'll show you why in
just a second. Uh but this is where all
of this activity is going to uh to be uh
happening underneath. You can almost
think of as a project as like a
particular feature, right? So you have
feature A BC and they they may each have
their own uh unique projects. Speak very
high level about the use case here.
Unreleased AI. What we're trying to do
is build sort of an application that
looks at a a GitHub URL and looks at the
uh the commits that have happened since
the most recent release. And the idea is
to inform us as developers what's coming
in maybe a a subsequent release.
Once we've created our account,
uh I'll come out to the Brain Trust
platform here.
So I'm gonna kind of follow along with
all y'all. I'll create a project, right?
unreleased
AI. Uh then you're going to need to
configure your AI provider, right? And
so this will be the the open AI API key
that you'll configure. Again, here are
the different AI providers that that you
can uh you can configure within the
platform. You also can use uh default
cloud providers and then like I
mentioned, bring in your own custom
providers to the platform as well. Uh
configure that and then we'll come back
to the guide.
Uh this is where the repo exists, right?
It's a it's a public repo in our brain
trust or you just clone this locally.
Zoom in a little bit. Um obviously I
have it here uh locally. The next thing
that we'll do is uh we're going to copy
this uh env.local.ample
example file to AENV.local.
Uh you're going to replace the brain
trust API key and OpenAI API key with
your specific keys. Optionally, you can
uh include this GitHub token. This will
allow you to not hit sort of like rate
limits on the GitHub side. Not super
important for for this. We're probably
not going to hit that here with uh just
running a couple examples, but that's
essentially what you do, right? We're
just going to run that CP command, and
you you'd have that there. fill in your
uh your API keys.
Okay, let's do this now. Uh so the first
thing that I'll do is run pnpm install,
right? This will install all of the the
dependencies for this application. The
other thing to call out here is it's
going to run this command uh after
installation. So this is going to
actually create some of those resources
that that Carlos was just talking about
uh it's going to create a couple
different prompts. It's going to create
some scores and actually create a data
set within that project that we just
created. Uh so this is I think just to
highlight here one of the really unique
things about brain trust is being able
to connect the things that we're doing
within our code to what's happening
within the platform itself. couple
different ways to actually utilize or
use the uh the Brain Trust platform.
Whether you are kind of maybe strictly
codebased using our SDKs or you are
using a lot more of the platform itself,
you can do a lot of these things and and
share code and and so on. But just to
kind of scroll through here, this is how
I'm creating my prompt. Maybe scroll
down a little bit further. Here's
another prompt. But when I run this,
this is going to actually go and push
all of these resources into that project
that we just created.
Okay, cool. So, we have our prompts, we
have our data sets, uh we even have some
some scores here down below. So, let's
just kind of investigate some of these
different things that we created. So,
here's my prompt. Uh as Carlos
mentioned, we have that sort of uh
mustache syntax here that allows us to
uh inject certain things based on uh you
know whatever our data set looks like.
Maybe to back up thinking a little bit
about what Sarah said in her talk,
thinking more about like that that data
structure that you that you want and
then this is how we will then create
that that underlying data set. But this
is really going to map to uh the data
set that we've created within that repo.
Right? So again, what we're trying to do
is we're trying to get that list of
commits, summarize them, and give them
uh give sort of that that summary to
that developer of what's coming in that
next release.
Uh the other thing to highlight here are
our scores. And luckily, um I was able
to follow most of Sarah's uh best
practices being very targeted in what
we're doing with these individual
scores. Uh to highlight a couple, I'll
I'll just open up my uh completeness
score.
So this is really uh just being able to
understand did I did the LLM do a good
enough job uh when it looked at the
commits is the summary complete right
when it did it summarize all of the the
breaking changes did it summarize all of
the net new features right so this is
where we can actually start to uh create
that criteria that uh that that meets
the expectations that we have of what is
excellent what is good and so on and
then this then maps to individual scores
between zero and one uh the other one
here I'll highlight here is this
formatting score right this is actually
just um you know more of that heruristic
uh just being able to understand is it
following a particular format that we've
laid out uh and this is a little bit
more binary just a zero or one but just
to give you a sense of the the different
scores that we can add to the project
uh last one I'll highlight is just the
the data set uh if you if you look
through here and maybe I'll zoom in a
little bit further right you should
start to see some of these things
actually map uh what we have within
within that prompt. And so this is how
we're going to be able to pull those
things in and actually run our evals.
All right, come back here. Make sure I
haven't uh skipped any steps.
So now that we have a sense for what we
just put within the platform, let's
actually start uh playing around with
it. Uh so we're going to go into our uh
eval playground. So this is where we can
actually create sort of evals on the
fly. Um I'll create an initial
playground here.
Feel free to name it something better
than that.
And uh here's what we can do. So let's
let's load in our two prompts that we've
created. So we have our uh change log
one and our change log two.
uh thinking back to what Carlos was
talking about of like the different sort
of components of of an eval, right? We
need our task, right? In this case, it's
our our prompts. Uh we need a data set,
and then we need an ability to score it.
And so we can actually include all of
these different scores here.
And now we have all of the different
components to run an eval here within
the the platform. Uh so I'll click run.
And then you'll actually start to see
all of these different rows within this
data set actually run in parallel. And
then we're going to uh generate those
scores against the output that the LLM
um created for those individual prompts.
And we should start to see some of these
scores come back uh pretty soon. Lots of
different ways to actually go in and you
know you can uh highlight each one of
these different things. you're able to
actually if once this starts to come
back look at the the rationale that the
LLM gave to providing the score that it
that it gave but this allows you to like
you know then you can even look at at a
diff again once this uh some of this
stuff comes back
or we can maybe get a more of a summary
type layout and I can look at like okay
so my uh accuracy score for my base
prompt up here or my base task how does
it compare relative to my comparison
task so very very quickly I got some um
some scores here that give me a sense
for how well these particular prompts
fare against the scores that I've
defined against against them. Um maybe
another really quick thing to to
highlight here is is up here at the top,
right? We were talking a little bit
about like maybe understanding over time
how are these things fairing as I start
to change these prompts. That's where uh
experiments come into play. Uh so I can
create an experiment again very quickly.
It's going to use what I've configured
within the playground. This will
actually create uh again we'll back up a
little bit here to experiments. But now
I can start to track over time these
scores. Uh I can change the model of
these. There's a lot of different ways
to start to view uh this data. Uh maybe
I want to understand what does cost look
like uh for these particular tasks over
time. I'm able to look at that. If I
change the underlying model, I'm I'm
able to group it by that model and see
how those models affect that score. But
this becomes a very trivial thing now.
All right, going back to that
playground,
maybe I I want to test here with GPT41.
How does this uh impact my scores? And
then how does it impact my scores
relative to the cost maybe that I'm
current incurring to do that? So run
that experiment again. Now I can track
these things over time. Um maybe maybe
really quickly as sort of a a bonus to
this um going a little bit off-grid here
uh just because I've actually heard this
numerous times at this conference and I
just had a question over here was like
how can we like automatically optimize
prompts. This is something that we are
thinking about internally uh and
hopefully within a couple weeks or so we
can release this this feature to our
customers. But this loop here allows you
to uh either optimize prompts or
generate net new data set rows. And and
the kind of unique thing here is that it
has all of the context of this
playground. What are the uh the
evaluation results the last time it ran?
How can we uh change this prompt to
ensure we beat those results? And so you
can see it's I'm guessing most of you
all are familiar with uh something like
cursor. So, sort of a similar type of
interface here, but it'll actually again
use those results, start to change the
prompt. Uh, pretty soon we'll it'll uh
give me like a diff here. Here is maybe
a a better prompt that we can accept.
And then it'll again it'll run those
scores for that new task.
And it'll it'll give us a sense for
whether or not we are better or worse
because of that. But now this becomes a
little bit easier to do that iteration
when we have sort of AI layered here um
in the mix. And and another question
that we got in the the previous uh
workshop is are we using brain trust to
actually evaluate this and and we
certainly are.
Yeah, this is really cool. This can also
improve the data set, right? You could
ask it to enhance the data set, add
another row, maybe even highlight some
of the data set rows and be like, can
you improve the prompt based on these
specific scores? Yep, absolutely. Yeah.
Really cool.
Any questions that you guys may have?
Yeah, we can open it up. Yeah. How do we
add if let's say we have a homegrown
model, how do we add it in the list?
Yeah, that's a good question. uh custom
AI models being used in Brain Trust.
In the settings here in the AI
providers, you can add your own custom
model. Uh so if it speaks OpenAI, you
should be able to add it in here or
choose whichever one you want if you
have it in inference.
Yeah. What if your score does not have
like upper bound that you can convert
into percentages? So, how do you
calculate score then?
So, what kind of score would you be
thinking about here? So, for example,
I'm building finance uh ticker, right?
Offering like buy some kind of stocks
and I use score as how much money I
made. So that could range, you know,
from $10 to like $10,000, right? How can
I convert this like percentage score?
Is that value relative to something
that's expected though? Like you're
talking about like an unbounded range.
That's not necessarily what I think
these scores are designed to do, right?
But I can engineer my prompt and try to
maximize some kind of score that I can
get, right? But that does not mean that
I have a range in which I try to
operate. I'm just trying to optimize a
function.
I'm generic that I'm, you know, defining
my score.
Yeah, it's definitely something we've
heard before. Um I think that's part of
the the struggle of writing scores is
trying to normalize them and and bring
them into that range of zero to one. So
up to you of of what you decide the
floor and ceiling are.
Yeah. Do you have anything for
evaluating multiurren conversations
and as part of that would you be able to
review the agent features?
I I think you kind of went through that
earlier, right? Yeah. In the playground,
we can just
so here at the bottom you can add more
messages. So the idea is that you could
provide a whole back and forth in in
context and then evaluate that
multi-turn conversation at once. You
could do it as well in the SDK. And then
for the
the agents here, uh the idea is that you
can chain multiple prompts together.
Uh so here we could just grab the two
but the idea is that the output of the
initial prompt will become the input of
the next and so on and then you can
evaluate them as a unit right and as
opposed to the the multi-turn right
you're providing all the context at once
whereas here it's you know making
multiple LLM calls
I'm just piggybacking on this question
for a multi-turn scenario do we score
each turn versus the entire conversation
also how What about if the conversation
has let's say 100 messages in between
the agent and the user? Um what about
the memory? Do we retain the context for
the message one versus the message 90th
message? How does this all play out? Do
we score the entire conversation versus
each turn? With the multi-turn extra
messages approach, you're providing
everything at once to the LLM. So it's
one LM call. So yeah, you would need to
comply with the context window of the
model that you're working with. Uh the
agent feature though each prompt is its
own LLM call. I think maybe just
speaking also more generally um if I
come back over here I just wanted to
highlight something because I think it's
relevant to the question
um do do you do you evaluate sort of
like the the individual turns? Um to me
like it's always like somewhat dependent
but if I look at these logs here uh this
is sort of like this uh this application
where there's multiple steps that have
to be taken for the user to get the the
output that it needs. So you can see
here uh that the first step is actually
rephrasing a question. Right? So there's
actually this chat history that is
needed and then the the most recent
input and we need to be able to rephrase
that question into something that the
user actually means. And if the uh the
rephraser here, the task that we have
for this falls down, it means the rest
of the the application is going to fall
down. So I think one of the the things
that becomes really powerful here is the
ability to actually score these
individual calls as they're happening.
So I have a rephrase question. From
there, I'm going to determine the
intent. But if I scroll down a little
bit further, I can actually create
scorers for those individual spans. So I
can understand the like the application
has all of these different steps. I want
to make sure that like if something does
not work, if the output doesn't match
what I would expect, I need to be able
to go back through there and figure out
where it fell down. I don't know if that
helps at all, but almost like a session
trace then, right? You're going back
through the session and seeing what
happened and where does the tracks.
Yeah. Yeah. And and you're able to
configure scores for these individual
spans that are created.
Does brain support uh evaluating speech
to speech models like photo or multi
model
evaluations?
Yeah, that's a good question. We have a
cookbook about evaluating a voice agent
that you should check out. It would be
through the SDK.
Yeah.
Any questions? Cool.
Are you guys able to follow along in the
activity? Like the internet's working,
everything's okay? Sort of. Kind of.
Sort of.
Yeah. We do. You guys offer brain dress
as for onrem installation?
We have a hybrid deployment. So we would
manage the control plane, you would
manage the data plane, everything meets
in the browser similar to the data
bricks model. So yes, our response is is
you would have the data fully in your
VPC.
Yes. Question over here.
Not how different I know.
Yeah, that's a good question. And so the
the question is how do we compare to
Langmith since we're both in the eval
space and you know I think you're right
and that we're do very similar things
and maybe if you're looking from a
distance it looks like it's the same but
up close what we hear is that our UIUX
is more intuitive, cleaner, easier to
work with and uh crucially the the
performance and scale of Brain Trust is
unmatched due to our underlying uh
infrastructure. Brainstor was actually
developed in-house and it was only
possible because of the technical team
especially Anker and the founding
engineers that have you know deep
database knowledge from working at
single store mem SQL and having built
many databases before so they were able
to increase the the full uh text search
capabilities and yeah
cool so finished with Activity one.
Again, this will be available for you
guys to to do at your own pace at home
whenever you want. Uh there's also a
free tier available for Brain Trust. So
you you have still a bunch of credits to
use. So moving into the second lecture.
So now doing the same thing that we did
uh via the the SDK. So we got to see a
little bit of the code, right? We cloned
the repo. uh we uh pushed the prompts,
the scores into the brain so we could
use them in the playground. But here
we'll actually do an experiment via
code. Uh so just wanted to quickly go
over high level how this works. Uh so
you know the the top row we went through
uh you didn't really get to see the
assets defined in code but we talked
through the brain trust push and then
how they ended up in the brain trust
library. So the second row is what we'll
go over now where you're defining the
eval.
You're running a brain trust eval
command. This can occur via the CLI or
in a CI pipeline. That's very common,
right? So when you're trying to to open
a PR and merge it into main, you would
trigger this eval process and then all
the experiments would appear in brain
trust. Uh and you know Sarah was
mentioning that they have their own
process that looks at those experiment
scores, summarizes them with an LLM and
then writes a report. Uh so you can get
creative with this pipeline.
So pushing to brain trust very similar
right the the key here is defining the
assets as code. So you would just follow
the pattern uh to the right here
projects.prompts.create
or it would be project.scores.create
create and then you would just define
what would appear in brain trust and and
this could be used in production. Uh you
could you know a lot of people will
either push their prompts into brain
trust or pull them. Uh really the the
prompt management style is up to you
but it's it is really helpful to have
that uh source controlled prompt
versioning in place. uh depends if you
want to go push or pull.
Running an eval via the SDK is very
similar to what we saw in the UI. You
need the three things again, right? So
you need a task, a data set, and one or
more scores. Uh so we'll show you what
that looks like in the actual code, and
then we'll we'll run the command and and
we'll see what that looks like in the in
the UI. And then we'll come back and and
do some of the logging. day two moving
into production stuff.
Cool. Uh back to the guide here. Uh if
you're looking on activity 2. Uh we'll
start again with just kind of
understanding what we have within the
codebase and then we'll actually run
some eval you you'll again like Carlos
mentioned you'll see some similarities
with what we did within the platform but
now we're just kind of strictly within
the code. Again, just trying to like
hammer home here. There there's like
multiple ways to actually uh interact
with the brain trust platform. Uh trying
to meet you all where you want to be. Uh
but if I come over to the codebase,
uh again, this is where the
resources.ts, this is where all of this
will be defined. All of our pro uh
prompts, scores, and such.
I have this eval folder. Uh I'm going to
open up my change log.ts.
One thing to kind of highlight here, um,
if you, uh, if you name your files with
that eval.ts and then you pass just a
folder, we can pick up all of those
evals and run those within the platform.
But, uh, let me open this up a little
bit. So, this is really all we're doing,
right? So, we have this eval, right,
which is coming from the Brain Trust
SDK. Here's our data set that we've
created. uh the task that um you know
that lives over uh here from uh from
brain trust and this is really like
again all we're doing from the the repo
side to run evals within the platform.
So I'll clear this and then run pnpm
eval. Uh this is again just another
command that is uh unique to this repo.
All we're doing under the hood is
running this brain trust eval and then
giving it the name of this file. But you
can actually see the experiments uh
running right now within the platform.
Here is the link that you can go out to
and this should look very similar to
what you just saw when we ran the
experiments within the the UI
specifically. But but now again this
this becomes uh part of the uh the
history of our experiments for this
particular feature and can track this
over time. But now we are kind of
strictly within the code while we are
while we are running this.
Um maybe just another thing to kind of
highlight I think I did last time but I
didn't really um pull anything in here
is is different ways in which we can
start to um compare this. So maybe we're
we're really worried about sort of like
the the duration or we are worried about
sort of the the number of um completion
tokens. there are different ways in
which we can start to view the the data
here. Uh again I didn't change actually
I did change the model right this is
another way in which we can start to uh
understand the the scores for the
particular model but again like this is
all just happened via via code uh some
simple commands that that we just uh
wrote on our command line and push that
into the brain trust platform.
Cool. Any questions about running evals
with the SDK and that evalu
command?
Yeah. Just wanted to
vision models and stuff. Does that work
with the UI or is that only?
Yeah, that should work with the UI
images. Yeah.
I have like
not like a grounding model as part of my
pipeline.
Yeah, that's a good question. Um
I'm not sure if it will let you add it
as a custom model. Um
yeah, I can't I I would say go try it
and see and and if there's any issues,
we have a Discord channel and you know,
we could add it to see if more people
want that feature. Yeah.
Yes, Python based SDK. Yeah, we have a
Python and TypeScript based SDK and then
we have some additional ones in in other
languages like like Java or Cotlin that
um Ruby that are created with stainless.
So they're just wrappers of the API.
We're uh creating a Go SDK as well.
Great. Any other questions about
activity 2? Ready to move into uh
production and we can talk about
logging.
All right, let's do it.
So, why should you even set up logging?
Well, you know, there's a few reasons
here. Uh the main reason is to measure
the quality of your live traffic. Uh, so
this will allow you to to set up alerts
if you'd like of when it starts to dip,
right? If you're putting out less than
your best work and users are noticing,
maybe they're providing feedback or, you
know, maybe they um, you know, the
scores that you have on those specific
logs are just dipping. Uh, you can
notify the right teams. you can debug,
troubleshoot a lot faster by having that
visibility into all of the functions
that are running, all of the the LLM
calls going back and forth. Um, and
crucially, you can close the feedback
loop. So, you can capture the feedback
and you know, we hear a lot of customers
that are doing that, but they're not
implementing it into their uh iteration
process. They're not changing the
prompts or or uh adding it to data sets
and and closing that loops. And this can
really help you do that.
So what does logging into Brain Trust
look like? Uh we have a very easy path
which is wrapping your LLM client. Uh so
you if you're using OpenAI, you can just
use the the wrap OpenAI function around
it. Uh if you're using the Versell AI
SDK, we have a very similar thing. So
this is essentially like one line of
code and then now everything is is
getting tracked. All your metrics,
right? the the amount of tokens, your
latency, uh all the cost, all of that is
getting populated in in brain trust. Uh
you can also trace arbitrary functions.
We have the same sort of wrapping
approach where you you use a trace
decorator or wrap trace and it will uh
track everything occurring within that
function. If you want to be more
specific or more granular or have more
flexibility, you can also do that. We
integrate with OTEL and we have a
span.log log support which can allow you
to add any additional information
metadata that you want to track uh and
add it to to that interaction
and initializing the logger. Right?
That's important because it tracks which
project you want this to be synced to
and it authenticates you into brain
chest. So that's part of the process.
And uh in the code repo that you clone,
you'll see that if you go to the
generate root.ts, ts you'll be able to
see all of these uh steps uh in the code
and and understand what's needed to to
get it into brain trust.
So now that you have the logging and
real user traffic entering brain trust
you want to have that uh assurance of
quality or you want to have that
visibility into into quality of
responses and a great way of doing that
is through online scoring. Uh so this is
going to use the scores from your
playground or from your experiments
right from your offline eval
production environment into that live
traffic and uh giving you scores that
you can then use to to filter down the
logs grab the you know underperforming
use cases and add them to a data set
keep iterating keep improving.
You can also do some AB testing, right?
You you tag certain uh logs in different
ways and you can compare the online
scores uh for each one of those.
So, we'll show you in the activity how
you can uh set up online scoring rules
and which spans you can uh enforce them
to be on and uh the sample size. So, you
could choose to to online score 100% of
the logs or 1%. It's up to you. We do
recommend for you to start with a low
sampling rate and then work your way up
as you trust the metrics more and more.
So, this is a bit of the process and
then Doug here will show you in the
platform how you can go about creating
the the rule.
So once you have online scoring set up,
it's really helpful to have one-click
lenses of what matters to you or to your
team. So you can think, you know, if
you've used notion, you've probably
realized that they have views, right?
You can customize the filters, save it
to a view. Same idea in brain trust. You
can filter, sort, do whatever you want.
Save it to the view. it'll uh retain
that those settings and then your team
can just use that. So it's a great way
of moving quickly defining uh the the
filters that matter to you.
Great. So now back to the platform, back
to the repo and go over logging and
online scoring.
Awesome. Let's uh let's configure some
uh some online scoring.
All right. Uh before before we do that,
obviously we need to like get some some
logs into our brain trust project. Uh to
do that, we'll come back to our
application and we're going to spin this
up. So I'm going to run pnpm dev. This
is going to run this uh localhost 3000.
So again, the use case that we're
building for is that that change log
generator. Uh the idea here is you
provided that GitHub URL. We're going to
give you um you know the the LLM will
give you the summary of those commits
and then maybe categorize them into
different uh different categories. So uh
I'll click that. This should go through
the process. Actually, while it does
that, let me come back here just to kind
of um highlight where this is all
happening. So uh just kind of connecting
what what Carlos was talking about like
how we can start to instrument our
application. There's a few different
things here, right? We have our uh brain
trust SDK from or for TypeScript
obviously and we're going to wrap the AI
SDK model. Uh so this is really going to
give us a lot of uh goodness out of the
box. Uh being able to understand like
the metrics, right? What are the the
completion tokens, what is the cost, all
of that stuff happens simply by just
wrapping your uh the LLM client with
that. Uh that's again like really the
the easy way to do it. Then there's uh
being able to like uh you know
instrument your application with a
little bit more granularity. And so uh
maybe you want to use this trace
function from the logger to actually be
able to specify what that input is, what
that output should be and then add some
metadata. The reason you might want to
do something like this is now this maps
to the the data structure, right? That
becomes really powerful to set up those
scorers against, right? So we start with
something that's very basic where we get
something very easy out of the box and
then we can go down to the the actual
like you know the individual tool calls
if you will uh and then actually create
the inputs and outputs for that so that
we can then create scores on top of
those.
Uh back to the application here right
here is the you know essentially the
response from the large language model.
Uh coming back into brain trust,
we should now see a a log and then this
is essentially what just happened,
right? Because of what we configured
with that wrap AI SDK as well as the the
different logs that we had set up,
right? So there's this top level uh
think of this as a as a trace and all of
these uh sort of under the hood or
underneath it are the individual spans
that we actually want to understand.
This this allows us the visibility into
the multiple steps that the application
will take and allows us like I like I uh
showed you in that previous example to
create scores for these individual spans
as well. Uh but you can see here right
the top level generate request here is
my input right what are my commits for
this repo here's the URL and then here
is the output but then being able to
drill down into these individual things
right so what are my commits what are my
what is my latest excuse me release uh
and then again being able to uh to drill
down into these becomes really
beneficial as we start to need to
understand how our application is
performing
from there right just going to come back
here uh we now want maybe set up some
online scoring. So, uh we walked through
both uh within the platform running
experiments walked through the SD SDK
running experiments as well. This is
pre-production, right? This is uh now
when we have our logs running in
production, we want to understand how
our application is performing uh
relevant or excuse me uh relative to the
scores that we've already configured.
So, I'm going to come back into Brain
Trust, click on the settings,
and then the
where am I,
excuse me, just configuration over here
on the left and then online scoring. So,
this is where we can now create the
rule. uh let's say this is
um this will allow you to select the
different scores that you've configured
within your project. Now uh I could
select all of these or maybe I have like
in that example uh that I showed to you
previously. I really just want to apply
this to a particular uh span. All right.
And this allows you to get very
granular. Right now, we'll just
configure all of these for the the
overall trace, and we'll do it for 100%
of the uh the samples.
Okay. So now when we come back to our
application
and when we generate this, we'll have
the same sort of workflow, right? We're
going to generate this uh the logs will
look the exact same as they did
previously. But now we are going to
score this uh we're going to understand
the things that are happening with
within production. How does this output
fare to the scores that we've um
configured for this particular task?
This allows us to understand. We could
even create automation rules here. So
maybe a score drops below 50%. whatever
it is, we can now create sort of an
automation that allows us to understand
when something like that happens.
So you can see here uh we have uh our
scores ran again you can you can drill
down into these things uh and you can
see you know what is the rationale for
that particular score in that instance.
Um maybe the other thing here and then
because we had uh some good outputs, but
this is where like we would want to
think about um how do we give users the
ability to to traverse through these
logs in a really uh scoped down way. Uh
this is where what Carlos was talking
about with with views. And so maybe it's
being able to understand um let's if I
open this up and I create a filter on my
completeness score and I'm just going to
modify this slightly. I'll say less than
uh 50%.
This now can become a view that I save
uh to
this project
and now it becomes really easy for
somebody to come through and look
through these logs and they can start to
understand the inputs and the outputs
and if if it makes sense we can add
these spans to the data set. That's
another thing that uh I think you think
about like the the the the sort of
feedback loop uh that we need here. We
were we're kind of like in prepro,
right? we were developing uh evals in
the UI or uh in our codebase, we pushed
it into production. How do we create
that flywheel effect from those two
different places? This is part of it,
right? Being able to uh enable sort of
like the the humans uh looking at these
things and then being able to add those
really unique or relevant spans to the
existing data sets or even creating net
new data sets from them.
Cool. That's uh activity three
questions. Yes. Can you aggregate those
scores
average or
if you go to the settings
aggregate scores here. So you can do
that. So uh like yeah you could create a
true north right and just based on the
aggregate score decide if it's improving
or regressing. So, so the SDK is meant
to be pushed to production and get all
those data. If you want to do online
scoring, you'll need to push scores into
brain trust, right? So that they can
then be referenced because online
scoring, if you're using the SAS model,
right? We're running that compute. We're
we're exe, you know, we're grading the
the logs.
Um,
so yeah, I think when you would want to
push to brain trust is for online
scoring. If you have teammates that are
using the playground and they want
access to the prompts or the tools that
you've made in your SDK, that's when it
makes sense. Uh, but you don't need to,
right? Like you could still do
everything with code and get value from
from Brain Trust.
Um maybe just to highlight really quick
um we also have just sort of scores out
of the box that you can that you can
configure. Uh so if I go to
the playground like if you don't want to
push up certain things now there's not
as much flexibility in this as as there
are with your custom scores but there is
an auto evval package that is developed
internally by us that you can use to to
add to these uh these tasks as well. And
then you can use uh an online scoring
also.
Any other questions
about logging or online scoring?
Okay, cool. Now we're going to move into
the human section. Human in the loop.
My favorite part.
I'm needed. All right, let's go. Let's
get into it. So yeah, it's it's honestly
really helpful for certain companies to
implement human in the loop, right? Not
all AI mistakes are created equal.
Depending on the industry that you're
in, like healthcare, finance, or legal
tech, a single failure can have, you
know, huge serious consequences. So
that's where you may want to have and
invest more resources in putting humans
in front of those AI responses and
making sure that they're up to par.
This can be really helpful for catching
hallucinations, especially in uh
specific fields that require specific
knowledge, establishing ground truth.
So, if you're going to start filling out
that expected column in the data set of
ideal outputs or you know, ideal
responses, it may be helpful to have a
human help create that. Uh and um you
know you also want to capture user
feedback and make sure that that's being
incorporated in your feedback loop and
and being used in in the prompt
iteration.
So, this is great for quality,
reliability, providing that ground truth
and aligning with what human uh humans
need in specific areas where the the LLM
just doesn't have as much uh visibility.
There are two types of human in the loop
that we're going to cover. Human review.
Uh so, this is an annotator and a
subject matter expert that's going to
come into Brain Trust. they're going to
manually label a specific data set or a
specific log, right? They'll score it or
they'll audit outputs. And this is
really useful for ground truth to the
data set. Uh they can audit certain edge
cases and they can also help uh uh eval
the LLM as a judge. So based on what
that human annotator determined was a
good response, you could train the LLM
as a judge to also label it the same.
And then for user feedback, that's, you
know, closing the feedback loop. You're
incorporating what your real users are
thinking. If they keep thumbs downing a
certain edge case, you can incorporate
that feedback and add it into a specific
data set, you know, and that is then
used to to help improve uh that that
problem that you're dealing with.
So that's it. You know, now we're going
to jump back in and show you how you can
enable user feedback and set up human
review. And at the end, we'll we'll do
some questions. We also have a bonus
lecture and activity about remote evals
that if you stick around, we'll probably
have time to get to.
Cool. Uh let's jump into activity four.
Obviously, we're going to look at uh
user feedback and human review. the sort
of like two different uh routes here
with human in the loop. Maybe to give a
little uh background here or just to
give you show you where some of this is
happening.
Uh if you look at API feedback and then
route.ts, the the one thing I'll
highlight is this log feedback.
So this is really all like what we need
on the brain trust side. Again using the
the brain trust uh SDK
uh we know of the span that we want to
log this to from uh the current span
that we are in. This is the user
feedback score right so this is like
essentially what we're calling it user
feedback and then the score in our case
it's really just going to be a thumbs up
or thumbs down so a zero or a one. We
also optionally have the ability to add
a comment. So if the user uh like your
application has the ability for the user
to define uh you know free text you can
also put that in here as well. And then
also of course using metadata metadata
is becomes really powerful from the
filtering aspect. Uh so like we can use
this within our custom views to filter
on these different metadata uh keys.
Uh coming back to the app and you may
have seen this uh at the bottom when we
ran this last time.
Um but we have at the bottom the the
thumbs up and the thumbs down. Uh this
will allow uh the application here to to
log this particular user's feedback. So
based on what they think, we can you
know obviously do a thumbs up.
We can submit with comment. And now if
we go back into the brain trust
application, we have that net new log.
We have uh over here on the right we
have our comment from the user. And then
we should see a net new column here
within our uh within our logs for that
user feedback. But again, as as Carlos
pointed out, we can now use this in a
lot of different ways to help augment
the workflows that we've already
created. This can help um you know,
create custom views on top of this. This
can now uh feed into a workflow for our
like human annotators to understand what
that user feedback is and whether or not
we should incorporate it into other data
sets. again being able to click here add
a spando data set and so on.
Uh that's the the sort of user feedback
route. Um the other one is the the human
review. So back in our configuration
pane over here
uh we have the ability to create
different human review scores. So again,
this will be a little bit more specific
to uh your your use case and what you
want your uh humans to to review or the
scores that they should they should
create. Uh it could be a an option, it
could be a slider, or it could be sort
of free form uh text.
Um, so we could say something like
what's a a better score? Uh, and then
give it sort of an option, you know, uh,
thumbs up
and thumbs down. So, sort of like, uh,
the human now can sort of look at what
the output was and give their own sort
of, uh, thumbs up, thumb down of this.
And now if you come back into the logs
UI, uh users have a different uh users
that are doing human review can have a
different uh interface into those logs
where maybe something like this is a
little bit too much for what they're
what they're trying to do. Let's give
them a little bit more paired down uh
look at the u at the inputs and outputs
of this particular span. And then they
have the different scores that we've
configured over here. Right? And so
maybe this is a thumbs up. They'll go
through and they can do that review.
Again, this now uh can add to that that
sort of flywheel effect that we need to
create to build this this Geni Gen AI
app.
Um, of course, yeah, I think I mentioned
this a few different times, but being
able to now uh add some of these spans
to the the data set, uh we can do that
uh here as well.
So now we we should have you know uh if
you look at the the sample data we had
seven rows through this process we've
added two net new rows to this data set.
This now can help our offline evals and
really create a a rigorous sort of uh
workflow to building a robust AI app.
Cool. Uh any any questions? Yes. So
those human evaluator they have to have
their own account.
Yes. But how do you how will they see
those uh vals that they need to
evaluate?
Yeah. So you can add them to the
specific project that you would want
them to to annotate. You could assign
them. Uh so we have the ability to add
comments under specific under data sets
under experiments or specific trace. You
would tag them in something that you
would want them to see. We have
sometimes, you know, you'll create an
experiment and you'll assign it to a
specific annotator and they'll go in and
fill out everything uh in that
experiment or in a data set. Yeah. But
the sorry the first one is developed by
the
shown in that web page where you have
thumbs up.
Yeah. So the actual
op like the text box that you want them
to fill out or you know the the
categories that you want them the thumbs
up or thumbs down you would define
initially and then you would let them go
in and and they would say okay based on
completeness I would give this a thumbs
down or you know uh what what is the
ideal output let me use this text box
and and type it all out. Uh so so yeah,
you would essentially create the form
that they would then go and fill out.
Any other questions?
Yeah, this isn't so much emails, but I
saw your documentation that you support
like writing tools and uploading those
as well injecting those in your um like
the evaluation, right?
Is there a way to like version the tools
as well?
So like how can we keep track of that as
well in the system? Yeah, that's a good
question. Yeah, I believe it supports
versioning. Um
I guess this project doesn't have any
tools. No,
I'm going to give you a soft like yes,
it should be versioned. Same with the
prompts and and scores like they all at
the very bottom if you create a tool and
add a new version of it. At the very
bottom we can show you with the prompts
potentially if
yeah. So at the very bottom we see this
one version that was initially created.
But if we were to go in and make a
change
save version
now we'd have that new version. So I
believe the same thing would happen with
the tools. So like you would like add a
tool to this that would just be like a
new version.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. If you were
to add a tool or change the prompt at
all, it would be a new version of the
prompt. You'd save it. It would now
appear at the bottom. And your question
was specifically like in tools, right?
Like if you change a tool, would it be
versioned? Yeah, I guess because you
have like different Oh, thanks. Um, I
guess you have like different prompt
versions, then you have different tool
versions, and then you're going to like
evaluate those, like mix and match those
together, right, to like see which
performs the best.
Yeah. So, there would be a scenario
where the tool doesn't change, just the
version that you're using in the prompt
changes. And how would you then version
the prompt, right? Yeah, that's an
interesting scenario. I I think we
version it correctly today, but if
there's any issues, you know, the the SE
team is here to help. So, feel free to
to reach out. Great. Thank you. Yeah.
Any other questions?
Human in the loop.
Okay, cool.
All right. So, now we're into the bonus
session, I believe. Oh, not this one, I
guess. Let's see.
No bonus for you guys. No. Uh,
this one has it.
And it's
Oh my god.
Okay, we can just do it this way.
All right, so the new bonus session.
Look at this. Extending playgrounds with
remote eval.
So, as you've seen, right, the
playground can handle
one LM call being made. It can handle
multiple LM calls chained together,
right? The agent feature. But if you
wanted to have intermediate code steps
uh in between the prompts, not
supported, right? You'd have to go via
the SDK. Or if you wanted it to talk to
uh these external systems that are part
of your VPC, that also wouldn't work. Or
essentially, if your task gets too
complex, it is not it doesn't fit into
the mold of the playground at the
moment. So that's where remote evals
comes in. It allows you to expose that
local environment that you've set up in
your laptop that has all the bells and
whistles, has everything that you want
set up, you can now make that available
in in the playground.
Uh so if you have custom internal
tooling, intermediate code steps, you
know, a dynamic R&D environment that's
constantly changing and you don't want
to keep pushing tools or pushing scores,
everything into brain trust, then you
can just set up a remote eval and it
will become available to anybody in the
playground. Uh so this is a great way of
bridging the gap between very complex
technical teams building crazy tasks in
the SDK and non-technical people maybe
PMsmemes that still want to be hands-on
still want to to iterate on the prompt
change certain parameters and see how
that impacts the scores. So the remote
evals can really help there.
So how this works right brain trust will
send an eval request to your remote
server. This can be local host or you
can set it up somewhere else. Uh your
server will then run the task and the
score logic all locally. So you all the
intermediate steps crazy business that
you have going on it'll all work because
it's occurring on that server. Same with
the scores. You could have crazy complex
scores that would all work as well. Um,
and then it will return the outputs, the
scores, metadata to brain trust and
it'll populate the playground.
To start this, it's very simple. You do
the same brain trust eval and then point
to a specific eval.ts file. The
difference is that you use the d-dev
flag. So, this will start that remote
eval server. It will default to local
host, but you can change it. Um and it
will allow it to bind to to all the it
will allow it to listen to all the
network interfaces so you could access
it uh via yeah access remote servers out
in the world.
Cool. So now we can get into the
activity. We have something to you know
in if you follow along with the activity
document you could set this up yourself
but if not we can just show you quickly.
All right let's first look at the the
code. It's going to look very similar uh
to what I showed the the first time. Uh
slightly different prompt, just trying
to layer in a little bit more complexity
here within this task. We now have all
these different parameters that we want
the user to be able to define and don't
yet necessarily have the ability to do
that within or in a great way within
within Brain Trust. Again, this can this
can be very very complex. uh whatever
sort of like you know the intermediate
steps that you want to create uh
certainly allowed here. I'm going to
take down this server and I'm going to
run uh this command pnpm remote evval
which just under the hood is running
that brain trust eval and it's giving
the the location of that file that we're
running the remote evval on
back in the brain trust playground. This
now is exposed as something that we can
um we can load in here.
So let me remove this.
I'll remove this here as well. And now
if you look down here, we have this this
other option for remote eval. And this
should link out to my change log
generator eval. Here are the different
perm excuse me parameters that I'm able
to now configure uh that I've sort of
exposed in that prompt. But again, now
think of like the the more complex type
of workflows that that you may have uh
within your codebase and you don't have
the ability necessarily to push those
into brain trust. We can still leverage
this platform with that existing
codebase via remote eval. And this sort
of like uh interaction works very
similar to to what I showed earlier with
uh the eval locally via the SDK as well
as the the playground.
Um, we should Oh, well, probably have to
Oh, we need to configure that my scores.
Uh, I'll switch this to the grid layout
so we can start to see what the uh the
output is. Uh, but this is how we can
really uh meet a maybe more technical
team with a more complex task and
they're not necessarily wanting to push
all of these things into the brain trust
platform, but still leverage it in in
some way. This is how we can sort of uh
bridge that gap.
And grounding this in the notion use
case, they use a lot of services, right?
They have a lot of tools that will
retrieve different user information and
they run all their evals via the SDK and
if they notice that there's an issue,
right, it's underperforming in a certain
area, a certain edge case isn't great,
maybe they isolate a certain row that
they want to keep rerunning. Currently,
they have to go to the SDK and run
everything over and over again. So, if
they were to use remote eval, they could
bring that custom task into the
playground and they could isolate just
one row and run it on one specific thing
that they're working on. They save money
and they'd move faster. Uh, so that's
something that we're going to discuss
shortly with them and a lot of our other
customers. This is a brand new feature
and it's something that we've been
hearing um a lot of excitement around.
So I hope you you see the vision of
where this could be effective. Um
and yeah, feel free to, you know, if you
have any questions about remote evals or
about anything else in the presentation,
we've pretty much reached the end. And
thank you for sticking around. I know
it's uh been a long day to say the
least.
[Applause]
For the remote, you need to
for the
for the remote. Uh how do you need your
IP address publicly available so brain
trust can hit it or uh yes or you can
use localhost?
Um, so I mean I guess yeah I I can't
imagine like if if it's uh private then
Brain Trust wouldn't be able to to
connect to it.
Okay. All right.
Any other questions?
Great. Well, thanks everyone. Hope you
have a a good night and we'll see you uh
tomorrow. Day two.
[Music]